merci d'être avec nous philippe Dominati
pendant cette première demi-heure et
l'île de Paris à parenté au groupe les
républicains rapporteurs du budget
sécurité dont on va parler dans quelques
instants mais d'abord un mot sur cette
interview hier de Gabriel Attal dans les
colonnes du Parisien la France
laborieuse qui se lève tous les matins
en ayant le sentiment de travailler pour
les autres et notre priorité c'est ce
que déclare le ministre des comptes
publics c'est une phrase aux accents
très sarkozymes vous vous en réjouissez
oui il vaut mieux s'intéresser
effectivement à ceux qui effectivement
se lèvent tôt travaillent et essaye
d'avancer dans ce pays ils sont très
nombreux souvent ce sont les oubliés
quand même les Oubliés y compris du
gouvernement lorsque je vois que le
Président de la République parle de
direr dans dimétropole c'est très bien
mais commençons par payer et que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
sur la région Île-de-France puisque pour
vous les RER c'est pas c'est pas ça sera
pas financé ou alors sur des
collectivités
annonce on dépense de l'argent on ne
sait pas gérer et c'est la pagaille
alors donc essayons déjà de faire bien
ce qu'on a du mal à faire on vit une
situation particulièrement
crispante en Île-de-France en ce qui
concerne les transports collectifs il y
a diverses responsabilités mais c'est
pas normal on va revenir là-dessus
évidemment longuement sur
l'interview la suite de l'interview de
Gabriel Attal qui dit qu'il présentera
début 2023 un plan de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et sociale c'est une
bonne mesure vous l'attendez c'est
normal c'est son rôle c'est le rôle de
tous les gouvernements de lutter contre
la fraude fiscale et sociale ça avait
été suffisamment fait jusqu'à maintenant
oui il y a eu de forts progrès au cours
de la dernière décennie de forts progrès
parce que c'est d'abord je dirais une
tendance internationale ce n'est
possible que si les autres pays s'y
mettent et c'est l'intérêt de tous les
pays d'avoir de nouvelles recettes parce
que tous les pays ont des difficultés
financières
on va parler du de l'examen du budget du
projet la finance 2023 qui se poursuit
au Sénat vous êtes rapporteur des
crédits sécurité des crédits que le
Sénat largement voté vous allez nous
dire pourquoi on voit ça avec Alex tout
ça
[Musique]
bonjour philippe Dominati bonjour
du gouvernement consacré à la sécurité
oui c'est un peu une nouveauté car sa
dernière année la droite du Sénat était
plutôt critique vis-à-vis des budgets à
louer à la sécurité mais durant le début
de ce second quinquennat Emmanuel Macron
a promis une hausse conséquente des
moyens de nos forces de l'ordre avec la
fameuse loi locmi adopter cet automne
par le Parlement la loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires d'ici à 2027 pour ce
ministère et donc la première étape en
2023 la hausse d'1,5 milliards d'euros
du budget de la sécurité des moyens qui
vont permettre de créer des postes de
policiers et de gendarmes 8500 sur tout
le quinquennat et dès l'an prochain 2857
postes équivalent temps plein créé dans
les forces de l'ordre tous ces moyens et
bien ils vont aussi servir à la
transformation numérique de la police et
de la gendarmerie pour développer ses
outils numériques mieux lutter contre la
cybercriminalité et puis aussi améliorer
la relation numérique police citoyen
alors les sénateurs alertent quand même
sur le poids des dépenses de personnel
au sein des forces de l'ordre un poids
des dépenses de personnel qui est
beaucoup plus important que les dépenses
de fonctionnement et d'investissement
qui servent à améliorer les moyens
matériels de l'exercice de nos forces de
l'ordre et puis après les feux de forêt
dramatiques de cet été en Gironde le
Gouvernement est également développé une
enveloppe budgétaire de 240 millions
d'euros pour renouveler nos 12
canadaires également renforcer à les
moyens de nos sapeurs-pompiers pompiers
philippe Dominati enfin cette année la
droite du Sénat approuve totalement le
budget de la sécurité du gouvernement
oui il faut dire que dans le premier
quinquennat ce n'était pas une priorité
du gouvernement il y a eu d'abord
plusieurs ministres de l'Intérieur
presque tous les deux budgets tous les
18 mois on avait un nouveau ministre
c'était pas la première mission et
majorité les manifestations qui ont eu
lieu parmi les forces de l'ordre ont
incité le chef de l'État prendre
plusieurs initiatives les beaux de les
rencontres de Bovo le livre blanc la loi
de programmation loi de programmation
qui s'est faite un peu dans la
précipitation de la campagne électorale
on a même voulu la faire je dirais à
tout à fait à la fin de la dernière
législature notre crainte nous au Sénat
c'est que le ministre de l'intérieur a
été malin et opportuniste dans le bon
sens dans la mesure où il a pris les
crédits du plan de relance à la suite du
covid pour équiper ou rattraper un
retard d'équipement pour nos forces de
sécurité la gendarmerie la police
nationale donc c'était une bonne chose
nous craignons qu'au début de ce
quinquennat le plan de relance ne
fonctionne plus par exemple les voitures
grises de police que tous les parisiens
peuvent voir dans la rue c'était un
effort exceptionnel les munitions de la
gendarmerie l'an dernier ont été payé
par le plan de relance non pas par la
Mission sécurité et donc on s'est dit
l'effort va peut-être s'arrêter la loi
le premier 15 milliards de plus pour les
forces de l'ordre sur 5 ans c'est une
bonne chose donc les forces financier
continue et donc le Sénat a prouvé le
budget de la police et de la gendarmerie
cette année comme l'an dernier à cause
du plan de relance et donc on est très
vigilant dessus d'ailleurs la moitié des
budgets que dont j'ai été le rapporteur
ont été rejetés l'autre moitié ont été
acceptés lorsqu'un effort on accepte et
donc vous diriez qu'avec ces moyens
supplémentaires le gouvernement en train
de résoudre le malaise qu'on connaît
depuis des années
parce que vous l'avez souligné notre
principal critique c'est que il y a un
effet d'annonce qui consiste à dire je
crée des postes on crée des postes
supplémentaires pour la police et la
gendarmerie
la création de poste le problème c'est
que la création de poste se fait au
détriment du fonctionnement de
l'investissement et ça ou sinon on le
dénonce il y a 10 ans les frais de
personnel c'était 80%, et le
fonctionnement d'un investissement
c'était 20 %
cette année c'est 14 % et 86 %. donc en
réalité il y a un dérapage au cours
d'eau au cours des 10 dernières années
pratiquement lorsqu'on a créé
des postes ça a toujours été au
détriment des voitures du parc
vieillissant et surtout de l'immobilier
cette année les mesures catégorielles
qui ont été faites pendant la campagne
électorale au mois de mars avec les
accords
spécifiques plus le la hausse de
l'indice de la fonction publique fait
que c'est beaucoup plus fort que
l'immobilier de la gendarmerie qui est
vêtue dans beaucoup d'endroits je parle
même pas de la police parce que les
locaux sont extrêmement beaucoup des
lieux ont signalé ce problème est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux 200 brigades
supplémentaires sont 3200 brigades de
gendarmerie ou est-ce qu'il vaudrait
mieux mettre à niveau l'immobilier de la
gendarmerie parce que mettre des
gendarmes dans des locaux V8 c'est pas
une bonne manière pour commencer un
métier
et donc c'est un peu ce qui nous permet
de nuancer je dirais ce bilan parce que
les intentions sont bonnes il est
évident que mettre 15 milliards pour la
gendarmerie et la police on y est
favorable par contre la répartition de
ces crédits mériterait peut-être d'être
vu ceci dit la cybersécurité c'est une
vraie problématique
la mise à niveau de nos services sur le
plan de l'informatique au manque
d'officier police judiciaire parce que
il passe plus de temps à essayer de
résoudre des problèmes je dirais de
procédures et de logiciels que d'être
sur le terrain et sur les enquêtes il y
a également ces difficultés sur une
forme de la police nationale ça ne fait
pas partie du budget et ce n'est pas
budgétaire mais cela fait partie du
débat
la réforme la palestinationale qui est
impacte la police judiciaire et qui a
suscité beaucoup de critiques alors
Gérald Darmanin a un petit peu décalé la
mise en œuvre est-ce que vous pensez que
ça ira jusqu'au bout c'est très fort
est-ce que vous souhaitez aller jusqu'au
bout écoutez ça ministère ou on a besoin
de réforme en réalité comme je l'ai dit
il y avait un certain désintérêt au
cours du premier quinquennat là il y a
un ministre qui a pour lui la durée
maintenant il commence à avoir de
l'expérience il est peut-être même à la
période critique tous ces prédécesseurs
n'ont pas duré aussi longtemps sous le
président Macron donc il est peut-être
en danger mais comment au début du
quinquennat on peut estimer qu'il va
rester encore un certain temps
Réformation Finistère qui n'a subi
pratiquement aucune réforme depuis les
attentats donc
je pense plutôt une nécessité la réforme
elle est peut-être pas judicieuse
d'ailleurs et il recule en réalité elle
devait être mise en vigueur au 1er
janvier maintenant on parle du second
semestre il y a rien qui est prévu dans
le budget après il y aura les Jeux
Olympiques c'est peut-être une manière
élégante soit de faire une adaptation
nécessaire à cette réforme soit
peut-être l'abandonner avec une certaine
discrétion ou c'est un enterrement d'où
ça non non parce que je pense qu'il y a
quand même quelque chose à faire le
problème de la police nationale par
rapport à la gendarmerie c'est d'être
incarné et de retrouver un peu peut-être
une unité mais peut-être que sur ce plan
là moi qui suis parisien avoir d'un côté
la préfecture de police et de l'autre
côté la police nationale deux tiers 1/3
c'est ça pourrait être inscrit dans la
réforme d'ailleurs le ministre m'a dit
que ça serait le cas après les Jeux
Olympiques alors peut-être que ce serait
un ensemble après les Jeux Olympiques
merci Alex à tout à l'heure dans le club
on parlera des soignants non vaccinés
exactement ce sera la suite un peu plus
d'une demi-heure on va aller dans un
département on prend à des violences ces
Mayotte direction la commune de Kongu on
retrouve Anne perzolafon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédactrices en
chef du journal de Mayotte alors il y a
quelques jours on a entendu la députée
de Mayotte à l'assemblée de guerre
civile du Nil à feu et à 100 est-ce que
le calme est revenu
bonjour Ariane bonjour monsieur sénateur
oui le calme là le calme est revenu mais
on peut pas dire que il y ait une guerre
civile puis guerre civile en fait c'est
des centaines de jeunes qui vraiment
mettent le bazar qui sont très très
violents d'une extrême violence donc à
peine le calme est revenu sur sur une
portion de route vous allez une autre
vous allez avoir une autre portion de
route le centre le sud qui qui va à
nouveau être en flambée de règlement de
compte entre banque parce que ça
commence très souvent par là et en fait
on a une violence qui va crescendo
d'année en année c'était au départ des
barrages contre les automobilistes ça a
été des caillassage là on voit les
voitures de gendarmerie qui sont
caillassées et maintenant c'est des
attaques au Chambeau dans les
carrosseries sur des personnes et ça
atteint une violence son nom qui est
sporadique donc là le calme peut être
revenu sur une porte certaines portions
de route mais ça peut redémarrer
n'importe quand le raid est arrivé
rebondit sur les propos de Monsieur le
Sénateur nous nous avons une des forces
de police et de gendarmerie qui sont
formatés pour une population de 300 000
habitants mais pas pour une population
de 300 000 habitants dont la moitié à
moins de 17 ans et demi oui justement
parce que ils sont jeunes ils sont
jeunes ils sont très jeunes qui sont ces
jeunes qui s'aiment la violence
eux-mêmes ont
beaucoup d'enfants et une très nombreuse
filiation et petit à petit ne s'occupe
plus de ses enfants qui deviennent miner
isolés qui sont élevés par la loi de la
rue et ça donne une violence qui est je
dirais en décalage de ce qu'on est en
droit d'attendre
d'une société d'une
c'est de la barbarie quoi voilà c'est ce
n'est pas on n'est pas dans une
civilisation en ce qui concerne ces
violences c'est pas gradué et là vous
avez une question du coup pour pour
Philippe deux questions même pour
philippe Dominati et ben en fait voilà
là c'était la première question c'est à
dire lorsque c'est ces personnes sont
expulsées il faut absolument qu'on mette
en cadre qu'on mette sur place pardon un
cadre qui fait que il faut que leurs
enfants leur soient restitués parce que
là on parle de de centaines de milliers
d'enfants qui sont mineurs isolés et
donc fin de des centaines d'enfants
voire de milliers ça peut aller jusqu'à
3000 4000 qui sont isolés donc en fait
je sais pas si c'est possible de mettre
un cadre pour que ces enfants soient
réaccompagner avec leurs parents et
aussi vraiment là il faut mettre en
place des subventions parce que c'est
comme ça que les associations
malheureusement fonctionnent pour que
ces enfants soient qui a un
rapprochement familial avec l'île
d'Anjouan parce que c'est ces étrangers
en situation régulière viennent en juin
soit rapprochés de leurs parents à en
juin voilà c'est une demi-heure c'est la
grande difficulté d'abord de
l'application du droit international je
crois qu'un mineur isolé lorsqu'il
arrive aux frontières d'un pays où qu'il
est pris en charge par un pays il y a
toute une procédure ou d'ailleurs la
justice mêle puisque c'est le procureur
de la République qui qui doit prendre
une mise sous tutelle donc ça c'est
d'abord le droit international et
il y a un cas particulier lié
malheureusement à Mayotte c'est à dire
que si on connaissait les parents
évidemment il y aurait il n'y avait il
n'y a aucun problème mais la subtilité
c'est de
d'ignorer théoriquement la parenté de
ces mineurs isolés effectivement les
laisser sur l'île de Mayotte et même si
les parents ont peu à peu près les
identifier en réalité on peut pas les
identifier dans le droit autrement le
problème serait résolu donc il reste sur
l'île je crois qu'ils sont aux alentours
vous l'avez dit de 3000 à 5000 ils sont
très nombreux mais c'est simplement
l'application du droit alors après
l'état est-ce que l'état de nation
je crois que dans tous les pays on
l'applique donc le problème et c'est la
situation particulière d'abord il y a la
sociologie de l'île vous l'avez dit je
crois que presque la moitié de la
population n'est pas de nationalité
française à Mayotte donc on est on est
dans un archipel
cette moitié donc 25%. voilà donc on est
dans un archipel ou contrairement à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie puisque on se trouve
dans vous avez évoqué le voyage du
ministre de l'Intérieur
Nouvelle-Calédonie où il y a eu trois
référendums différents d'autres
détermination
là l'État français a considéré que on a
procédé il paril dans l'archipel et donc
Mayotte ayant répondu reste territoire
national et un département ce qui n'est
pas le cas en Nouvelle-Calédonie donc la
procédure n'a pas du tout été la même
dans un archipel et maintenant l'État
doit mettre effectivement les moyens
pour régler une situation particulière
et ces moyens il passe évidemment plus
par le milieu associatif qui est
probablement plus adapté que les forces
de l'ordre pour des populations mineures
je pense pas vous avoir répondu avec
satisfaction mais j'espère simplement
avoir éclairé nos auditeurs un dernier
mot
un dernier oui oui alors oui là
franchement c'est très important il faut
mettre en place une coopération
judiciaire il y a une entrée de
judiciaire qui a été nouée entre le
Sénégal et la France depuis maintenant
plusieurs années et en fait il faut
faire exactement pareil avec les Comores
pour que et notamment sur les ce qui
commettent qui sont redevables des de la
justice pénale pour qu'il soit
expulsé juger et emprisonné dans leur
pays il faut mettre en place une entrée
judiciaire je ne sais pas comment c'est
possible monsieur le sénateur mais il
faut absolument on peut a priori
identifier le pays puisque c'est les
Comores mais on a le même cas je dirais
dans le problème des visas avec par
exemple la Tunisie
l'Algérie et le Maroc qui dit ce ne sont
pas nos ressortissants nous nous prenons
que nos ressortissants et s'il y a un
refus des autorités d'accueil malgré la
proximité de des Comores c'est très
difficile pour démocratique de dire
j'expulse telle personne dont je ne
connais pas vraiment la nationalité je
ne connais pas vraiment l'identité en
plus et les mineurs c'est ça la
difficulté juridique de de cette
situation vous ne pouvez pas
automatiquement expulser vers un état
qui est les Comores qui dit mais moi ce
ne sont pas mes ressortissants merci
ils sont joignés
ils sont tous comoriens
rapidement il faut qu'on passe
il faut qu'il le soit par l'état civil
merci beaucoup merci Anne perzola font
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la une
journal de Mayotte lutte contre la vie
chère Mayotte sarde d'un bouclier
qualité prix renforcé c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de la
situation à Mayotte on va voir
l'actualité dans votre région philippe
Dominati la région Île-de-France et
c'est une actualité compliquée dans les
transports compliqués par les usagers
parce que les rames sont surchargées
compliquées aussi financièrement pour
les transports franciliens Valérie
Pécresse demande une augmentation de la
part des entreprises pour financer ses
transports à la raison non non elle a
pas raison et c'est même
choquant pour une candidate qui a été
candidate à la présidentielle en disant
on veut baisser les impôts être plus
proche qu'hier pour les entreprises il
va aller mieux hier dans ces conditions
parce que
d'abord le problème des transports en
Île-de-France et uniquement en
Île-de-France
c'est quelque chose d'étonnant par
rapport à ce qui se passe par tout
ailleurs dans le monde partout
d'ailleurs dans le monde il y a deux
sources de financement il y a d'une part
l'argent public que ce soit l'État les
collectivités territoriale et les
municipalités et les usagers et par
faciliter en Île-de-France on a associé
des entreprises et les entreprises
payent même deux fois parce qu'elles
payent versement en transport et la
plupart du temps 50% du Pass Navigo pour
leurs employés et maintenant les
entreprises en Île-de-France
représentent plus de 50% du budget les
usagers représentent un peu plus d'un
tiers entre 35 38% selon les les budgets
et les collectivités territoriales
c'est-à-dire l'État et la région
Île-de-France essentiellement représente
une faible partie
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est un
petit peu gonflé de la part des
autorités et notamment du président de
la République d'annoncer à chaque fois
des nouveaux transports qui ne sont pas
financés c'était le cas avec le Grand
Paris Express dans le passé ça a
toujours été le cas moi depuis que je
suis élu parisien j'ai toujours entendu
l'État et les gouvernements successifs
annoncent des choses généralement qui
arrive 10 15 ans après puisqu'il mettait
hors ou Éole dans le passé on a mis 10
ans et 15 ans de retard voire 20 ans
pour faire les infrastructures qui
étaient décidées théoriquement par
l'État mais payé par d'autres et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe c'est ce que
je reproche à Madame Pécresse c'est
d'être dans le même système ça fait
maintenant demande à Dieu qu'elle est à
la région Île-de-France c'était
normalement l'une des priorités de la
présidence de la région Île-de-France de
frères d'abord un système adapté elle
aurait dû revendiquer l'autorité des
transports comme il y a eu une évolution
dans région capital notamment avec le
statut de Paris l'autorité des
transports c'est effectivement comme
dans les autres régions de France
normalement la panache de la région une
société comme la RATP
de la région et donc de Valérie Pécresse
dans ses difficultés de ne pas avoir
anticipé le financement on est resté
dans la même ligne que le président
Huchon et la mutualisation avec la
complicité entre guillemets de l'État ne
fonctionne plus
c'est ce qui s'est passé on n'a pas
voulu remettre en cause un système qui
n'était pas financé alors au bout de
quelques exercices dès qu'il y a une
crise style covid fréquentation etc le
problème ne fonctionne plus madame
Pécresse par le passé a dû déjà demander
sous le gouvernement de Monsieur
Hollande des rallonges budgétaires ce
problème il est structurel il fallait le
dénoncer
en temps et en heure il faut pas se
présenter à des élections
présidentielles en disant tu peux
baisser les impôts et six mois après
dire ah bah il faut que les entreprises
payent parce que je n'arrive plus à
boucler mon budget ça c'est pas de
cohérence on peut pas dire à Paris il
faut les choses vont mal il faut mettre
sous tutelle une ville et à la région
les choses ont mal et on va dire que
tout est parfait donc donc voyons tous
les problèmes sur la table mais du coup
elle dit que s'il y a pas de solution
rapidement il faudra augmenter le Pass
Navigo à 90 ou à 100 euros qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ça ben je pense que c'est
une mauvaise chose je pense que c'est
une mauvaise chose parce que
effectivement le Pass Navigo coûte trop
cher
c'est le même prix le même tarif si vous
restez dans le même département et par
exemple dans le département de Paris
lorsque vous passez simplement de
l'Ouest pour aller à Jussieu vous allez
payer le même tarif que pour traverser
la région c'est la mutualisation qui a
été mise en place le gouvernement a
laissé faire on allait fait des tarifs
spécifiques par moments
chômeurs on a voulu pour les jeunes donc
il n'y a jamais eu de véritable
confrontations entre le gouvernement et
l'instance régionale c'est ce qui aurait
dû être mis sur la table et mais il y a
déjà quelques temps c'est peut-être un
peu tard pour le faire alors le chantage
qui consiste à dire je suis obligé
d'augmenter le Pass Navigo donc
finalement
des entreprises oui parce que les
entreprises sont représentées nulle part
l'État a dit c'est la région la région
de Nice et l'État les usagers n'ont pas
à payer autre une part plus importante
que dans d'autres régions d'Eu parce
qu'en réalité un tiers du ticket c'est à
peu près le prix qui est payé à peu près
partout ça peut monter jusqu'à 40%, mais
je dirais il y a pas de raison et donc
on dit finalement c'est financé à 50% à
plus 50% par les entreprises mais comme
personne ne peut en parler et bien on va
les augmenter mais moi lorsque je vais
dans Paris je vois le nombre de mètres
carrés disponible aux Champs-Élysées
dans les dans je dirais les beaux
quartiers vide parce que les entreprises
quittent la région Île-de-France
dit qu'il y a aucune justification à
mettre le Pass Navigo à 100 euros que
Carole Delga en région Occitanie a
baissé le prix des trains que vous aviez
Bertrand en région de France
à la région les pouvoirs qui donnent aux
autres régions sauf qu'en Île-de-France
la RATP qui est en réalité une
entreprise régionale voie l'actuel
Premier ministre qui vient de qui était
Président de la RATP et l'ancien Premier
ministre qui devient le nouveau
président RTP alors faisons de la le
faire de lance de la région et d'un an
les pouvoirs à la région là où Madame
Pécresse a raison c'est que le
gouvernement s'amuse entre guillemets à
se défausser de ses responsabilités
financières en lançant à chaque fois des
infrastructures mais en ne voulant pas
payer le coût de fonctionnement donc il
faut donner des
financements propres à la région mais ça
elle aurait dû le revendiquer depuis
quelques temps déjà merci Philippe
dominative merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on parlera de la course
à la présidence des républicains
dernière ligne droite l'élection c'est
dans 6 jours et dernier grand oral pour
les trois candidats c'était ce week-end
devant les cadres du parti mais d'abord
on va cueillir une autre élu de Paris
c'est Sandrine Rousseau qui nous rejoint
[Musique]